how do you know if you're actually in
ketosis
oh yes and bro well cuz are you are you
running on glucose or are you run enough
fat bro science and and and you got a
usually guess you know how you can do it
you can you can take it you can pee on a
strip or you can prick your finger and
do a blood test or you can get keto the
breath sensor that consists of a
bluetooth-enabled breath sensor that
detects ketosis that's right all right
you just do it on your phone it's that
dang easy super expensive I don't like
uh spend nah man for just $99 it
provides keto level readings as well as
access to kilos upcoming food products
within the app for only $8 a month users
can subscribe a keto premium for access
to videos articles recipes that's my
favorite part
restaurant guides you know how much of a
beast is when you go to restaurant
trying to forget what's keto what's not
what's gonna drop you out of ketosis be
Aikido kid but you can't do without
knowing exactly what you put in your
body and if you're in ketosis get the
keto premium right now it's the most
accurate easiest way to measure your
level of ketosis and get real-time
personalized feedback on your diet via
that app you don't
can you help you lose weight and improve
your health and feel better get keto I
spelled K ey like the keys for your tio
get keto key GE TK e YT o calm slash
spider 20% off your first purchase stay
skinny friends where's your whoop-whoop
do you always have it on that's always
have it on I even have a sudden mark
from it yeah I was hiking today and they
took a shower took it off took it off I
took it off you could wear in the shower
if you wanted you could I just you know
like they got because I sweat there so I
took it off clean your rush in the
studio arrest yeah cuz I thought all
right my phone told me I hiked this far
cuz tracks my steps
yeah but then woop went me actually
didn't like that phone you burn this
many calories this is your heart rate
also last your real keeps you honest
whoops hit honesty video also I thought
I thought I was getting eight hours of
sleep we went oh excuse me sir you can
about six point four hours of sleep
that's not good I know oh so now you
gotta take a nappy poo yeah it tells me
when to rest how my output my strain all
that also if you're doing the sober
October with Christ sure
freaking Brogan rere mom they're all
using Moop to track all their movements
I thought it's the most accurate
thinking where to improve your window so
am i I'm still waiting for mine or do I
have to just go to whoop wh Opie calm
and use code fighter code fighter a
check out to save $30 and optimize the
way I train maybe I can pull some
strings and have whoop send me one for
free so whoop will send you one for free
and then you just got paid then you got
to pay for the membership and it
connects your phone it does everything
by your heart rate calculates your hurry
a hundred times per second twenty four
seven hours a day your your strain your
rest or everything man Wow there's
nothing better
woop calm use code fighter at checkout
safe three dogs and optimize the way you
train everybody gave me the Limpy mic oh
dude yet the limp one well you don't
know how to use a mic obviously well
we're gonna take it away oh no Frank you
got to talk into it Frank
hello now that's nope nope you got a
talking Bobby Lee does his stomach was
sticking out I mean the job just started
laughing I couldn't stop lovin kindness
titties were out mm-hmm the guy's a
black shoot black shirts huh that's cool
yeah well Frank I'm gonna say this about
Frank kalyana before we start and do
anything I'm talking to Will Sasso
casually fill well I can feel the sense
of them feel sad so they feel sad so you
guys you guys work together he's
brilliant well in the end good he said I
said about Kelly and I did this
impression it was so good and and
casually he goes well he I think he's
the best ever anyway so I was and he
start talking oh I go all your this is
coming from one of the best ever
yourself Sasso and he said that about
you so yeah are there I just of all I
don't think so well I doubt we'll I
think so about me
no absolutely will will didn't see what
wills done better than me too
is he did a lot more characters and he
blew them up bigger and wilder the
impressions as well yeah like the Kenny
Kenny yeah I'm Kenny Rogers this is
jackass people I'll text will I'll be
like people thought I was you again he's
like that's fine people thought I was
you yeah we'd go places because we were
both a fat guy on MADtv at some point
hey how'd you get your nose back no I'm
not already laying yeah he had the first
time I met you and I mean you guys know
each other from MADtv no no I met him
when he was a new cast member and I was
doing something in LA and there was a
party and they just had you do they
started laughing because they had you do
Robin Williams and those all I saw and I
went that's the never seen and then I
went on that was one of those that like
I tried to really nail to like to me
most of the time it's better to do an
impression and make a caricature out of
it have a take from the person yeah that
that makes it a lot more fun and that's
what allows you to do a longer sketch if
you just do the person exactly yeah the
sketch is pretty much over
you don't have a point of view on him
but Robin Williams I walked around cuz I
worked it into a baseball softball place
giving out tokens gotta tell ya who's
incretin a golf course grounds crew in
high school oh and I would just walk
around I was the annoying guy who was
working on impressions just doing
impressions for people as Robin Williams
like oh my god you're not gonna believe
what this token what's at the end of the
rainbow you know that kind of stuff and
I'm just do the serious the serious one
I didn't want to do serious what you did
it's the really fun the one will you
grow a beard and try and win an Academy
Award here's the thing about Brendan
right now he's actually trying to do the
face back to me from your background
mimic I make it happen oh it's crazy uh
eight right there yeah well your cheer
your Gruden I want one hard nice dude
did you see his Gruden yes well hard
night yeah that's the one who said hard
night near the game Brian last week goes
dude have you seen hard night do word
seven in the regular-season OVA I know
and now I'm on a TV show yeah busy do it
that's not you yet I'm just working all
right all right
hey my voice is that thin huh no because
I don't have I don't have where it's
going yet uh but yeah it's gonna be
incredible okay but you know trying to
capture my charisma is weird I have a
resting charisma on the unhard lock so
the team loved it loved it oh yeah they
would see this brood in such a character
are you nervous about doing that were
you nervous yes I'd done it last year
when they were down in the dumps and it
went over really well so I got a call
three hours before that they taped that
hard knocks oh and like come on come on
over
Jeff Leonardo and I always have to think
of his name and it's one of the Ninja
Turtles so Jeff Leonardo and I really do
go through that my brain and so he's
like come on over now or in a couple of
hours and I actually had to play some
ping-pong before that because as you
know that's what I do
yeah as a hero we play we we hit uh say
we have you at tennis
ma'am you would remember if we had
there's a ping-pong table out there Oh
is there yeah that's great cuz I brought
a paddle joking I always bring let me
see no way pal good you bring a paddle
everywhere you go yeah like Roy Hobbs
natural yeah just in case something
breaks breaks out huh this is fantastic
oh you're not [ __ ] around if you're
the guy like that he cleaned up and you
went straight to the FBI
holy Sh nice easier look and you got
covers oh yeah because this some some
places actually put up so the ball
sticks all right now hold on oh wow now
let me show you my strong and destroy
you you calm the [ __ ] down just joy when
it comes to Palace sports I'm dangerous
let me show you my stroke huh is that
why are you doing that to me that paddle
looks war it looks like you do a lot of
spin oh yeah this is this is called
penhold
this is yeah Chinese used to play like
this do you play far from the yeah table
if I need to probably play real close
against Brian hey hey let me see that
you're this bowling ball to the bowling
alley and then I'll poke you I play
saying like table tennis you bring a
table you bring your don't touch the
middle we've all done it though but but
you got a little this is this is this is
like from I hit a ball with it got
knowing me already hold on wait you
don't look like you're that's not you
got the two finger thing going oh that's
right you've played tennis tennis s
that's tennis yeah that's tennis B B
that's tennis let me you might let me my
Paul's on this Oh your hands are just
your palms are too wide you're too big
of a man this thing that's not for me
ping-pong let me show you that let me
show you the difference did you get move
what the [ __ ] is going on here Marco
you're like oh why are you so into it
Frank uh because I used to be really fat
and I'm just somewhat fat and it had
helped me lose a lot of weight that and
some running and eating better was a
little piece yeah but well people should
know that Frank's house in Arizona I
walked in give us your address right and
he's got it well he's it's true cuz he
owns the twelve houses on the block
corporate money uh and I walked in and
he has I think seven maybe eight screens
large screens in a room and sports are
playing sports bar that sports a plane
oh yeah but siblings yes yes yes it's
crazy couches what it's a little
different now I don't remember when you
were there you probably there five six
years ago it's nine TVs now it's a TV
wall you have 90 so you could watch nine
different football games or all in one
or you can watch like a couple or one
one game on four TVs and then the other
five are single games and on top of that
you had a guy there who just lived there
Oh Baxter Baxter
now hold on he had a guy named Baxter
Baxter look to me like I'm a butler but
it's more way to scraggly he looks like
he lives on weed Cheetos and all due
respect seems like a very nice guy but
not he's out of the hangover elephant
flight runs all those attack electric no
he doesn't do any of that way he he just
he makes sure that when things break he
calls people that's basically what it is
was like yeah call my house he's a couch
guy he works for me yeah yeah me doubt
like he brought me in the airport today
so he's more like a chauffeur I guess
yeah but people know Baxter great name
yeah what's his last name but the people
call me we still be smokes a lot of weed
no no no no no no I mean he's me my he's
just very I went to high school with
them and uh he's amazing he was he was
just that guy who was he was just odd
but he started to get into stand-up
comedy after after I when I started
getting into a couple years later he was
really funny in school and would just do
weird things like they they for the
homecoming parade they canceled the
homecoming parade after his year because
they had a car breakdown and then had a
renegade float go in kind of like an
animal house type of thing and it was a
poop float so they had like toilets and
they were throwing tootsie rolls and
stuff and this guy had watching my kids
sometime sure some time how long has he
lived there even when I lived in LA even
when he's your boy yeah yeah I mean he's
just he just worked just what else is he
gonna do 15 years then uh no probably
longer than that I mean literally
somebody living at our house that's a
weird thing we've been comedians live at
our house even when I had a even we
moved to Phoenix we and I still had the
house in it off of Coldwater Canyon yeah
we had people living that's Italian
is that what did I think so my mother
realized that you think it's rich no my
mother was that way the Italians will
have like the Italians would never have
an old relative living on home ever no
never
you'd have your the grandmother
grandfather live there but then you got
uncle's then you got
like that who just that's known forever
but they call it the kids call him uncle
Baxter yes I mean everybody's all kind
of family yeah but but everybody's like
that's a that's something from my wife
side who's more Italian yeah than me
she's and she rubs that in she's like
yeah she likes me to know that I'm half
she's found a half - what's the other
half
kind of Irish German yeah I just stuff
them with the same same mix yeah you
been you start standing up when what age
I I went up one time while I was in
college was I really started University
of wisconsin-milwaukee and my dad's from
there we talked about this
oh yeah but that's dumb things yeah okay
right well you dance from Milwaukee
yeah oh I didn't hear you because your
voice was good I remain slim regretted
saying it out loud because it doesn't
meaning I know no it's a that's a we
even when I went where'd you go I plant
but what I was thinking it and then when
it comes out like but sometimes that's
no I don't know probably cuz that's
always like when I meet people I always
find something that ties me into that
city yeah somehow or that state whatever
so I went to school for broadcast
journalism didn't want to work for real
didn't want to be at Eau Claire
Wisconsin asking people questions for
the local news so I started I went to a
comedy sports class and they're like hey
you should do stand-up I'm like does
that mean I suck at improv they're like
no you just do a bunch of impressions
and they're like go try that so I went
up and went up at a club and I actually
killed the first night which is well
compressions if you do him the way you
do yeah and I met it was so odd I did
weird once I did Tony Danza like I
wasn't going up there's like Johnny Dee
she beat the mold and whenever he would
see somebody from the old neighborhood
you know from from you know Brooklyn or
wherever it was in New York City with it
he'd be like turned super Italian like
Rosie like Wow Tony showed the acting
chops there so I was doing weird offbeat
impressions I did like Rick Moranis
like I'm the keymaster you the
gatekeeper I got out of shower and
people are like nobody's doing that dog
though so you your face do you do down
from now I did tremendous Donald Trump
it's incredible it really is don't know
what no because no I wasn't asking your
dad from Milwaukee
he's from Milwaukee tremendous man Thank
You Donald
can I ask you something I'd love for you
you're a tremendous man take a look at
you thank you do your than me of you I
don't know what that yeah a lot of
people don't know okay do you uh do you
work out what do you do to stay in shape
because I know there are a lot of
different things and a lot of people are
weight lifters another weightlifter and
there are a lot of people go running I'm
not a runner I'm just a type of person
that loves to stay in shape by staying
in shape and that's how I do it I just
continuously stay in shape in a shapely
manner I okay okay well you see Trump
has easy zombie yeah your weren't easy
no Abby oh you stole them from Frank's
son from Frank Frank Caliendo
Oh Frank impersonations and impression
Asians yeah not as good as will Setzer
no but very very good thank you for your
vote oh that's good that's pretty good
you nailed it my kid thanks for thanks
for your vote okay I haven't thought
about it but if I work on it I think
you've got it
well the most important and I can't do
it I always do that in my act I talk
about he I think he should be teaching
an aerobics class that would be fun or
just as your trainer
one more set we did it we did a bunch of
things that were Donald Trump if Trump
were before he was president if Trump
were a mime it's like I'm running into
the wind I go against what normal mimes
do have an outsider I'm telling you what
I'm doing that's the only way to go
perfect what else is here we did Trump
as a priest okay
it was like somebody came into his
confessional so what you're saying is
that somebody your neighbor is coming
into your yard they're trespassing right
maybe you should build a wall
build a wall but what I say is he's got
magical words and the words are and
everybody knows it so yeah he'll say
something that's totally out of this
were like there's a colony of people on
Mars and 100% of those people voted for
me and everybody knows it's just like
it's gonna be walking down the street
people like do you're about that colony
people on Mars a whole new person boom
Boulder for Donald Trump how do you know
everybody knows it and I'm not the only
one saying it who else is saying it
other people other people other people
couldn't be here but they're
tremendously tremendous group of people
they really are yeah it's so [ __ ]
true it's Jerry good lead on this weird
rabbit hole yeah yeah but they all
politicians do that I mean I Barack
Obama would he was hypnotic and talk a
slow at the beginning and speed up at
the end Ryan's always the two parts 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 so true there's music ality
totally yeah there's that that was was
that something he was doing on purpose
no I think that's well I think people
just learn it it advice as a comedian
you guys we all talk in a cadence
yes you find a cadence that works for
you and now that every joke has a rhythm
to it
sure tempo and stuff sure very similar
in music and yeah and watch watch a lot
of especially late-night comedians step
forward on the punch line mm-hmm see you
know even go back the Johnny Carson Bill
Maher watch the step forward and Leno
what always got punchline
yeah so you find you find something but
the step forward is always like here's
the punchline yeah I am the most amazed
by people like nor McDonald he's one of
the guys that I could just watch forever
because I don't under he's like a wizard
yeah I don't understand why it's so
funny he will say something that's Noir
sentence yeah did anybody would say and
you sit there and you just go why is
this why is this great theory on that I
don't have a theory on it but the norm
genuinely seems to not give a [ __ ] about
it's the greatest anything and what
anybody thinks like truly because he's I
guess this is public knowledge he's a
compulsive gambler from what I
understand and just and he grew up like
with nothing and so in a lot of ways he
he probably had nothing and is not
afraid to have nothing again there's
something about people like that
people's like not being clear
yeah it's an art yeah not almost being
not afraid to die it's almost like
having enough self-loathing but also
having the intelligence to be funny
enough it's it's in it but I think he
but he's one of those people that can
say things in a funny way and says
things that are thought you know
well-thought-out funny he's incredibly
witty yes but he'll say he'll do that
thing where he's like you ever you ever
go to the grocery store I ever gone to
the grocery store what he white and why
are we all laughing about the groceries
or makes his time yeah it's unbelievable
to have that confidence
well he's I remember when he he did a
Rolling Stone article he's on Saturday
Night Live oh and they asked him about I
think it was gene Garofalo or something
like that I mean it's a cast man he goes
and he goes never made me laugh once bro
thank you like you got a bad [ __ ] about
anybody if I'm you know I think what
else is crazy to me is a guy like Marc
Maron who has the cops just to sit on
the stool the entire time yeah Marc's
always been that way oh you just they
just on the stool
yeah Marc was that wait 25 years ago you
know he just just not a ton of energy
it's just him yeah yeah he's cerebral
Marc yeah I remember I had to follow
Patrice O'Neal in at Caroline's and they
had him feature for me he was just
filling in doing something that we and
I'd never seen Patrice work live and he
was you know I'd seen him on TV and
stuff like that he just he's just sat on
the stool told story he was kind of
chewing his teeth or his lip
just the whole time just doing this and
talking and the the audience just loved
him so much he also did about an hour in
the feature slot moving for trace until
he's done he just he had stuff to say
and I was intrigued by but at the same
time I'm going yeah it's uh it's
midnight already
and the it's been an hour and a half of
show and I haven't gone up yet can I
just do 15 and get out of here Wow like
nobody really knew who I was it also
didn't even matter but I'm like this is
brew cuz he's just killed so he just
hasn't been the palm of his hands he's
taught he's just taking his time I go up
and I got you know I'm like a puppet
show without the puppets just doing you
know impressions I have at that point I
have some jokes but I don't have as many
as I do now and I don't set it up as
well and I had no confidence in being
myself I was just good to be in the
characters at that point and I I did
alright I survived it was like a tough
go she's that's that's the real Dee's an
artist like here follow me I do tomato
leave yeah and he and he was young back
then he's just well I mean I I don't
even know I didn't even tell you the
year it was it was in the 2011 did you
do Mosher kind of stand up in New York
well you know I just was I was just
doing our lines that we hiked I started
in Chicago and Milwaukee my intro your
daddy surrealism that's right yes my in
Genesis O'Neill was was I didn't know
him I'd seen him out because I'm in New
York I would see him and but I never
paid much attention he was always great
and I'm sitting with Dov Davidoff and we
start talking and this is probably I
don't know maybe ten years ago maybe a
little less and he starts we start
talking about women and relationships he
starts dropping like knowledge on
relationships and how women have
different levels of karate different
levels of karate that they pull out year
one year five at America bro and it
wasn't comedy he was drunk and I at one
point I'm an old man I mean I've heard a
lot of [ __ ] it was so deep and so smart
that I went I looked at him and I looked
at Dov and I go you do you here in this
and dub discussed he drops a heavy truth
Brian have you you drops a heavy
if anyone under who he is getting ready
passed away but especially a new comic
he there was a ton of his stuff on
YouTube I watch it all the time
dude he has to be one of the smartest or
was the smartest comics to ever do a
conversation just on just that his
knowledge on just life isn't controlled
I mean they have on a show I feel it
might Bend Jim Norton's back in the day
they had him on there there's him Bobby
Lee and somebody else and his he was
auditioned for the office marinate Craig
Robinson got it he was audition for the
office and Bobby was in there and
they're talking about I think the
hangover and Ken Jeong got it yeah and
they were kind of not throwing shade at
them but you know that I said dude
you're such a better comp comic than
Craig and you know Bobby you're better'n
can and then per treat she's been quiet
the whole time it shows up late and he
gets into and you thought he was gonna
jump in with the you know dog pile on
top say no we I wish this and he goes no
no no we didn't get it and he lists off
why he they didn't get it and how
they're difficult to deal with and why
they're difficult him oh dude damn shuts
everybody down damn try to see there's a
lot of truth yes and that's I find more
nowadays then when when I started doing
comedy it was more like he did a lot
more jokes and you could even setup and
punchline a lot how long ago Frank I
mean I started in 96 was when I
graduated from college okay so but you
you know there were storytellers and
stuff like that but try and tell it try
and tell a joke now like a joke joke
people's like wants at Tara there yeah
observation observation or sarcasm irony
don't die no telling jokes jokes right
now is more tonight Jesslyn I can mark
Danon
those guys are amazing but that's a
different that's a different level of
joke - there's that usually has a lot of
spitting yeah but that's 15 and 20 years
in sure that's that's that's these are
veterans I mean home you talking about
just one day 15 years in 2020 yeah 20
years in so that when you're joking that
way those are jokes that are don't you
yeah but there are many people that can
they aren't made people that do it
so hard to pull off now because in a job
you know when something sells mmm yeah
why not II hmm like he's one of those
guys you work with for a weekend and
you're talking like him by the end the
end so like my actor being who wants to
hear some jollity mad and hmm you me why
am I talking like him now so [ __ ]
Harlan where's it another one like that
correct he's one of the great ones
dude I watched him the other day he's a
lady at the comic store bros he was
improvising and doing [ __ ] and then
taking my bits and rehashing them he's
just amazing probably just eat another
one that somehow doesn't care like it's
brilliant so but I I broke him down to I
brought some friends to go see him in
Chicago I went to this ace Comic Con was
out there that to get my dog and tell
you about that later but to get my
daughter to meet some Avengers because I
used my c-list status to milk anything I
can for my kids yeah I do
so I took him to see Harlan and Harlan's
just up there going hey there with your
Twinkie on the you know trying to find a
way out of the milk book like you tried
to figure out how he did then I realized
the type that he's Keyser söze he looks
around the room
hey there with your portrait of yourself
as a boxer trying to find your way with
the microphone next to it top hat over
there a Mexican wrestling match how's it
gone there Firefly said exactly what he
does he's just but it's like other
people can string together words and
it's kind of like that they're both
Canadian - oh when when the swine flu is
going on here sorry I got myself a
little case the bacon look who got a
bacon lawyer I was [ __ ] diamond he was
- how stuck pig people are ain't ever
what the play
I was who I was laughing that hard he
does the craziest [ __ ]
yeah he was doing that some guy who was
like you from Australia huh Australia
with your lemonade and your Barbies I
was like what the [ __ ] is he talking
about but it doesn't have to make sense
it's just brilliant the way does it
buddy no I mean he is you let you break
it down he also knows a little bit about
everything - and finds a way to work it
in yeah yeah I'm not I'm not even trying
to do it right now they're my friend
remember we did some we were even
talking about this we were doing some
bar in Santa Monica or suddenly one when
I just first started out and he was
talking about just came from an audition
with five guys who looked like me
it's me Dane Cook Bob Marley you ever
see Bob Marley but it's like for the
same guy yeah you know just doing that
and then I hadn't done many auditions at
that point and I just then I realize I'm
going to the additions with other short
fat guys so please stick to Sears like
that's what they think well shorter and
fatter and more the part right yeah
they're better had every [ __ ] time
oh my god Jesus yeah I thought I thought
I was a type until I saw that guy yeah
he's in addition you probably can't well
most of the movies I kind of miss it cuz
I got to a point where I started getting
a lot well that it took me forever well
you were you saying because you can't
though no no I can't can do movies
though yeah I can do movies so if you
wanted doing these if I want to tell you
in other words no I couldn't do movies
if I wanted to but if I want to take a
night Ron you have three of the
auditions yeah you cannot do it yeah
because my TV contract it's just yeah
there's no time no TV you can't do
scripted no right no ABCs really really
weird but also yeah pretty normal so
yeah you're in a contract I don't mind I
love doing the show yeah but then I went
I saw Joker there's a rumor you know how
I knew oh because it was a clown looking
into a mirror yeah
thinking I look this great with makeup
on
yeah when I look like without mr. Bryan
Callen that's Bryan Callen walked around
with a shirt off the whole day kept my
stomach tight though you know I mean
yeah suck it in you gotta keep a tummy
tight dude you can't have your tummy
loose some people just don't give a [ __ ]
I admire them I'm trying to keep my I
got to keep it tight you and push I you
know and you'd think you'd lose your
vanity at 52 no I don't let it go to I
lay down and Betty oh yeah same way yeah
I feel like when you were on the UFC and
you're waiting to fight who did
everything let go now you were holding
that in no way no way all puffs I'd take
my shirt off of a millions of people Wow
oh hey dude it never left Brennan has
body dysmorphia which I love said I feel
a little chubby he would be he's like a
he's like a hot chick who won't eat in
front of people he's like an ollie well
that does to girls there's a nice around
yeah hot should be Savage what I'm like
really like eating is a mr. although
they were looking at you here they're
like was that hot she was from come on
yeah
come on that show The OC from the OC hot
hot hot
from the OC who was cast of The OC and
they were looking at Brendon hungry eyes
her and her friend I could see it he
went over there and they were looking at
his shoulders they were like they were
looking at it the way you look at it
there she is Mischa Barton yeah that's
who it was
oh no it's Rachel is rachel is the the
the fourth the girl I feel like I was
meet rachel bilson yeah is Rachel oh
yeah yeah cuz I've always liked her
that's why I didn't eat in front of him
so meanwhile they're checking him out
not even a nibble
you know they hold it on a four that was
me chef I was starving to starving by
the way they're looking at him like he's
this they just had hungry eyes for the
giant you know right he's tatted up and
if think he was in a tank top and he's
eating pizza I was that that was me
Shabaab was it made sure I wasn't matter
whose mission it was me chef doesn't
make sure for sure of me sure well shout
out to Rachel though so yeah but she's
gorgeous and yeah I was definitely Misha
gorgeous yes so they're looking at you
say hi and and her friends just as hot
I'm I could have been a cup of coffee I
could have been a so I was a spore their
eyes might have like you were thrilled
they were like where's my rug
whatever what the guy was maybe they
you are out of their league you know my
thinking like you right now dude can I
get some of that thank you
that's exactly right because I don't
happen though that's a tire they're like
Amos no chance
like he's down to play game that's the
language oh I'm tired working TV actor
can't afford it can't afford it I'll
take prime take a run for it just
regular prime take a run yeah well
Brandon changes the whole site can I get
up to go box I go what are you doing
there's no starving eat all of it I go
it's two pieces of pizza what the [ __ ]
is I look like a fatty cause I eat the
[ __ ] pizza right now yeah it was
fantastic
we're all afraid I'm not
I just jaw down hello who's your
favorite team you're such a sports
fanatic I'm I'm a I'm not a huge sports
I'm a a sports fan me of not TV same IV
and III have to talk about sports a lot
oh that's part of you know I've had cuz
you were doing with Fox right yeah Fox
and I went over to ESPN social doing
that not really
I've been trying to do some different
stuff what are you doing now uh
different stuff difference hmm no I'm
just I've been out of it for a while I
wasn't my kids I was trying to help
raise my kids and now I found out that
they didn't need me the whole time I've
been fine without me yeah they need
their breaking I wouldn't swear I'd be
super clean because now I just hear my
son playing NBA 2k yeah and there's just
F this at just everything's fly hold is
he 15 and my son's 8 he's doing that
[ __ ] yeah he doesn't think I'm listening
[ __ ]
god damn I'm like hey dude I know I
swear all the time but you can't copy me
I tryna I bet I did
like he called me chuckle nuts don't
turn around I go hey he is alright
chuckle not psycho wait a sec that's
five years and he's the Chuckle nuts is
where's that he's from you or FINA
that had been for my son's [ __ ]
hilarious I've never said chuckle nuts
in my life but I got to tell you that in
a house be from you if there's a fortune
Allah forced born comedian that
motherfucker's head chuckling that kid
is a comedian through and through so I I
think
something about when your dad is a
commuter and a parents of comedian
there's something to that because my
son's the same way and my son is super
dark my son he named his phone so when
somebody comes by and wants to air drop
something or seize your air drop his
phone is named Jeffrey Epstein's phone
that's area so yeah it's a great joke
hey and so people yeah that's I think it
was actually the real Jeffrey Epstein's
phone my sons already making people
laugh and that's what I knows yeah he
has an audience
he can't help to turn it up he's your
son into sports he was for a while but
now I think he's just into girls and
he's got some hard classes so yeah my
yeah it's a he's way more advanced than
I was I thought I couldn't even talk to
her girl it's like a year ago he
couldn't even a couple years ago he
could even talk to like another human
being he couldn't look at somebody I
talked mother than I act to like like he
looked at talk to somebody it's like
they had a mold and a toupee and he I
couldn't figure out which one to look at
kind of a thing you know that was you
sometimes you like what's going on yeah
but then but kids will talk on two
screens so you give him the Xbox headset
is like we will form in a 2x2 form in
the middle of a fortnight
you know appearance so you're going I
don't even know who this kid is all the
time um but my and my daughter's funny -
I think she's funny she's a different
kind of funny she's like that was a good
one huh just leave there we go
was a good one wasn't and all she does
is make Avengers references she knows oh
like the Avengers she just I I don't
know she doesn't I think she wants she
broke her elbow a year ago on her
birthday and then she didn't it she
couldn't do it it wasn't healing
properly so she just had a second
surgery huge incision and it's a big
it's a big deal
found out found out today that she's
allergic to the glue that the stitching
you know it's just but in that time all
she doesn't say that I gotta take her
arm off
were you able to put down okay so I've
seen where we're going no no but she's
in that time where
things right where another was happening
where it wasn't she started just
watching these Marvel movies as all she
cared about so it was kind of her way
cuz she was a gymnast because look here
the genetic uh-huh that's what I was
thinking I thought Caliendo joong-gu
yeah were you into superheroes uh yeah
like comic books make sure who was your
favorite um I mean I like well Batman
was big when I was a kid I could keep
Batman like those have big deal okay it
came from movies and stuff like that
there's a certain generation that it all
started at comic book-y start comics and
then no cat man was the first like legit
movie of the comics oh I remember that
being such a big deal but me my brother
collected comics and I was always a
little business minded dude so I've made
my birth at all these comics and I drew
all these flyers put them around all our
apartments because I wanted my own comic
book store then we cleared out the
closet and I had like a little comic
book store in there my mom's like who
the [ __ ] are these random people come
through why are they I was just yeah my
neighbor was a second comic my neighbors
came in a box of comics he did a
plumbing job or something he's giving up
just now how much from this old lady the
guy died and this lady or someone gave
him this box at companies so he knew
better he was like these are
collectibles yep so I was there I'm
right near my neighbor and he's got him
out this is his buddy
this guy Billy's just smoking and got
him all out laid out on the table and he
say kind of smoking away and kind of
he's a plumber and he's looking them up
on on Google to see how much they're
worth and one I'm is worth $17,000 what
brett has like some Captain America
probably in mint condition
it's mission also its first edition so
he goes also helps Shepherd on old
people
well they said oh no this is worth
seventeen thousand dollars but then
there were a lot of them are worth
fifteen hundred yeah yeah crazy amounts
of money yes the most comics yeah so I
was like who the [ __ ] Wyatt though who's
gonna buy it I guess somebody somebody's
super rich or that really loves comic
books yep they're cars they're all
myself going down at eBay rabbit hole
the other day because I'm putting stuff
for a podcast we're doing
all I'm doing is getting all the stuff
that my dad and we sold at garage sales
back in spending like a hundred and
fifty dollars on things I had that were
like $8 when I was a kid
Godzilla the Shogun warriors all this
different stuff to put on shelves and
kind of decorate because that's just a
piece of me so we so the transition that
my daughter loves these these Marvel
guys and all this stuff Marvel people so
we go to this one thing called ace con
in Phoenix it's a comic-con but it's a
high-end one and Tom Hiddleston is there
who plays Loki and I seen him do some
impressions
he looked like Jim Tom Hiddleston oh
yeah Tom Hiddleston I am Loki oh yeah
yeah plays the bad guy yeah well he's
kinda he kind of goes yeah and it's I I
worked on the voices like I'm Loki of
Asgard and embedded with glorious
purpose so I worked at but I tried to do
it for him and it didn't work at all but
he doesn't he doesn't grits a bunch of
great impression so he started doing a
Jeff Goldblum yes yes Shawn why why oh I
is my favorite part-time haul it is I'm
doing stuff like that and we're just
going back and forth and my my
daughter's like starting to get upset
she's like how's your friend Tom like
she stole the show no because it was
just it was just fun to talk and stuff
and he was he did incredible impressions
and them in the meantime todd mcfarlane
starts drawing venom freehand for her on
a napkin and just go and just he's like
talking to her is like you know what
this is how I invented the venom I was
just doing this he's just going on and
on about us and then he gives it to her
and then he invites Juliet to come to
his office which I found out is three
miles down the same street I live on
next to her physical therapy place holy
Sh crazy right so at that at that ace
Comic Con I talked to some agents and it
turns out Tom Hiddleston or Tom Holland
is going to be in Chicago in the
meantime they were thinking he might be
in Seattle so we go to Seattle and I
have this video and audio of Josh Brolin
talk
about me being the inspiration for his
George W Bush impression size day in the
movie w and he's like Oliver and I when
we saw Frank Caliendo this is exactly
that was we're like that is how we're
going to do this movie and I'm going
that this is crazy I'm like I've gotta
meet Josh Brolin because of this of him
so I'm I'm working so hard to meet him
at that a scum but they're so busy and
doing all kinds of stuff we finally get
an opportunity and my my daughter's like
I want to see this panel with Don
Cheadle and Chris Evans and and like
four other Avengers on say cuz she loves
to just watch him go rip each other so
we missed that I go women might miss the
opportunity to go meet Josh Berlin she's
like it's okay I really want to see this
live so he sees how old she's 13 she was
12 at the time
well she turned 13 that day that was the
other thing was her birthday so she'd
broken her elbow on her twelfth you
gotta you got to do it
13th so so we get the moment that we can
go over and meet Josh Brolin and he's
like he looks at me and goes you're the
man you're the you're the man like yes
yes what do you mean it's like you don't
understand
he's like that movie that's me doing you
thank you I was like I don't know if
somebody prepped him or what that's and
I don't care at that point and and uh so
good and it just happens that Chris
Evans is there at the same time Captain
America and Brolin says to him this guy
is responsible for me for one of the
roles I did and Evans is like what role
and I was like Thanos and he's like good
heavens just like wait a sec Sicario
yeah he was wait a second who are you I
go Frank Caliendo goes [ __ ] it's like
he's like this is he's like the mad he
starts going and he starts doing things
from my act
that's like Easter cuz he's a huge
Patriots fan yeah starts talking
meanwhile Juliet's talking to Josh
Brolin about her broken elbow
I snap half the universe code no so I
she looks over and she goes
this is unreal because Captain America
is tight and I'm seeing stupid things
like just crap is coming to order seeing
that you're kind of yeah but I'm saying
ridiculous things like you don't
understand what it's like to be
pigeonholed as John Madden Captain
America just like terrible yeah like
stuff that obviously he knows what that
like on a grander scale yeah so we we
leave that area we go out because we're
shoot out by the photographers because
we're like eat there like you got to go
because the Evans just starts he's
talking more about this stuff is so it
was unbelievable so we go out and then
Chris Evans comes out a little bit later
and he sees me he's texting somebody cuz
he's taking a little break because
they're just signed an autograph it's
hundreds and hundreds of autographs he
comes over to talk to me more and then
we're just talking for a little bit he's
like I got to get back in there you
sticking around this weekend I was like
no we gotta go which we did but but then
Julia goes that was unbelievable I'm
like what she goes he didn't have to
talk to you that time he saw you wanted
to talk to you more this is the greatest
day of my life I'm like well it's only
downhill from here
[ __ ] and they well best birthday ever
wonder how he feels being typecast as
Captain America I would have after a
while he likes acting that much from
he's a heady guy a very smart guy and I
think he really likes directing and he
wanted to get out of acting yeah you
didn't like it he's he wants to do yeah
I'm sure if he were Great America strike
yeah it's worth it's worth a five nine
dollar he talks about eat oxidants he
talks about on stage he's like yet you
know it did a lot for me but I think
he's an artist he's a true artist yeah
but you look at people like that and you
see and they when somebody's that
good-looking that uh thank you dude
thank you very much okay but people
start to think about that only that
element and they don't you know you see
it Brolin talked to Brolin talked about
it how he was worried at first about
doing playing Thanos because he thought
people wouldn't take him serious yeah
and then he said then he saw the role
was
like let me see what I can do with it
there's always something and then you
hit Tom Hardy they asked him because you
know Tom Hardy's like you know legit
actor all right I guess Liz logistic yet
he said the only reason he did venom was
so his kid because his kids he he has
his key said he wasn't really familiar
with it they got the script and his kids
like whole venom he's like you guys like
this then they're like yeah he's like
I'll do it for you guys
while he did all you had wasn't gonna do
it did you ever see him and Bronson oh
yeah come on bro he's so good and good
that was when I was doing warrior with
him and I watched it the next day I was
like dude no he's amazing all you have
to do now hi Jackie
my agents here ladies and gentlemen
everybody relax everybody calm down all
you have to do with like a Marvel movie
or something like that now if somebody
says they're not gonna be taken
seriously Robert Downey jr. yeah he's an
incredible actor yeah he's very he does
such a good job with with Iron Man stark
again
that's an actor who always has a sense
of humor he's like there's always humor
in it like no matter what he's doing his
always humor behind it it no matter how
dramatic the scene there's always
something he's dying and he's making
jokes which is which is how people are
it's like we saw say an acting class
like they're the actors that go on stage
or go on film and they die they die
they're doing it to die and then there
are [ __ ] people who real actors do
what a real human being is which is try
to live hey remember when Robert Downey
jr. got nominated for an Oscar for
playing chocolate face yes I do
on topic Thunder yeah I do now we live
in set now we live in a time gonna right
demo no now yeah I guess that would be
as a sensor or wrote that movie know
that yeah yeah Justin Theroux yeah I
didn't know yeah no no no traffic
Thunder yes no no sorry I've met and
spent some time with the writer bring
that up yeah
pen spend some time to write em hmm he's
won yes yes but Downey has that ability
like you said it's them throws and
throws he acted it no no no I wrote it
be you wrote it look at writing please
I've had conversation with about it but
there's another guy right topic tropics
on the screen play Ben
they alert Justin through I don't think
justin theroux was in the film he's not
in it he's a writer he wrote Tropic
Thunder
it says written writers doesn't throw
and these are another guy yeah and I
just I just got done writing the wicked
enchanted yeah that's impressive you're
lying though I don't believe it in that
crazy yeah that's amazing you know I've
heard great things about you right
okay oh I have appeal Justin Theroux say
he said he's think I was married to
Jennifer Aniston yep I've heard such
good things about that guy mom's dad
he's the head writer you Wow I'm sorry
Who am I thinking of somebody I know
Henry David Thoreau no I've seen about
the Tropic Thunder I thought that was
that guy was I was with Todd Phillips on
a plane on my way to Montreal is me Beth
this view baptism and there was a writer
of was it wasn't was it you sure was it
just it wasn't that he wrote it though
so crazy right you should see how much
stuff he writes really Oh God
monster what a great just fat a right
that's all you said that I was like what
a commenter what a commenter yeah
freaking chocolate face man
Iron Man - mm-hmm Wow we should Rock of
Ages mm-hmm
amazing I had no idea he was that good
he's also kind of the North Star for
white dudes when it comes to style you
know most like urban communities it's
Kanye West
he's the North Star for white boys it's
amazing Nick he's got a he's got a
there's a cadence to him to Robert
Downey jr. Robert Downey jr. give me a
favor enjoy me he's a human Twitter feed
140 characters or less than everything's
about himself
mayor Ward supposed to be about the
nominees turn it back to him these
people deserve your applause almost as
much as I do hashtag awesome that's the
that's the whole thing I did a little
dish for Chris Evans he's like
doo-doo-doo Downey
deep down he I'm doing it it's like
that's that Downey he like and I'm
getting shut down and my daughters like
that's awesome he made fun of you I'm
like yeah he didn't like it she goes it
doesn't matter cuz cuz Downey was it
before Ironman Kalon you've done in the
dance
he was in jail for drugs or whether for
something else you went to jail for what
do you consider in the dumps yeah risen
to find dump to find he was truly in
jail the dad the judge said I'm gonna
make it very uncomfortable for you
I'm gonna make this very uncomfortable
for you because they found him sleeping
in a ladies crib in the baby's crib in
some lady's house and she's like Robert
Downey jr. is in my [ __ ] crib it was
like was it Margot Kidder or some
terrible weight a second I didn't no
longer trust your memory wait a second
maybe it was some lady's crib in a
baby's house it was there was a movie
that was really funny like written by
Thoreau how the [ __ ] wrote that's
amazing
he he basin's wait what's that son's bed
neighbor his son's bed yeah strip to his
underwear and stuff in this racecar in
my defense yeah he um oh there was it
who is the actress Margot Kidder or was
Margot something where she they found
her and she'd knock some of her teeth
out with a ball-peen hammer and pulled
her hair out cuz she was on drugs I
think that was that be metha it was
something crazy man it was bad
some people just they just it doesn't
drugs man I get it though you know
oh yeah that's real good D drug their
little I hear you do a lot of blood brah
huh look at you I've never even been
drunk you don't drink you don't drink at
all good no vices at all not eat
handsome I got some the taste that [ __ ]
no oh you do that the Frank man Frank is
clean yeah I know dude it's a plane if
you did that I just I don't know I
couldn't even tell you why isn't it
funny though how call me like like
you're not allowed to do that
you guys see the Chappelle special oh
yes like that very much
I finally watched I have trouble
watching comedy yeah I did you start
doing stand-up no start as an actor okay
if you have trouble cuz you mimic
something well there's some of that to
that yeah as I start to talk like people
I don't want to that
but I don't know I remember watching dr.
Katz professional therapist on that
Bensimon but it was Jonathan Katz
yeah but it was watching on a Comedy
Central years ago and I remember seeing
interview he's like don't watch any
other comedians because you'll get
influenced just do what you do
I heard I heard bursts say that he's
like I can't watch anyone cuz they plant
seeds and you never know now and then
also who Jimmy Fallon because that he
goes I had to stop watching comedy
because he needs directions and he's
Marc everything just impression yeah
founded amazing impression yes and he
was saying he would watch people stuff
then he found it slowly made it way into
Zach somehow he's not [ __ ] I didn't know
Fallon even did much stand-up yeah he
was like in New Jersey New York area
yeah upstate New York and it was like
kind of legendary for that troll doll
stuff he would do and legendary men yeah
but yeah I just I just don't want to
hear what other people because I want to
I'll watch it if it's if it's Chappelle
I had to watch to pal because I wanted
to see her great tall watch I talked to
I talked to you about this too after I
saw you cuz I considered that another
level as well thank you but it was it
was that when you were tired you did it
and a few comedians I've gone to see are
all doing everybody's kind of going this
against the grain thing and especially
in clubs nobody's staying completely PC
they're walking a line of and I think it
all comes down to tone like what's your
tone of something is your tone to try
and hurt somebody I get that as being a
negative but if your tone is hey we're
different let's celebrate our
differences and see if that can make if
we can make each other laugh with that
that's what it's all about that's about
compromise and let's get away with it is
that what you took from Chapelle special
though did you find I watch the Pels
special and I said this is this is great
this is helpful to comedians I think
it's first - yeah I haven't seen birds
yet I had to do them slowly cuz it says
I've had to force myself I know how
great Chappelle is yeah but some of the
stuff he's doing I'm going
it was rated so terribly by all the
critics and stuff it was the woke
critics because the critics are
terrified of taking a stand themselves
because then they'll get out it and lose
their status right we live in a society
where finding the the race is finding
the misogynist that's where you get
credit that's what you get currency from
that yeah you'll get currency from being
moderate and nuanced in your thinking
right trying to understand somebody is a
negative of course today's why I forget
what comic wrote this about critics
Yanis you know time' yeah go to his
twitter feature and he wrote this on
people who critique comics god it's
brilliant man Yanis topless yes is
intelligent critique but there is but
there's also I went and did I was doing
like shows where I was working on new
stuff dunes clubs
huh and just working on new non
impression stuff and building that in my
act and somebody came and reviewed one
of those shows on Monday night like what
why you reviewing that show the whole
point is for me to try citizen a lot of
it to fail three and a lot of the things
that person said was we're correct but
as a few days come on dude right I'm
warming up I'm working on my yeah the
your first draft I'm gonna grade your
first trip there you're on it in the
natural I think I think it's over
educated and useless liberal arts
educated kids why can you go yeah this
is the whole rant servers over educating
useless liberal arts as you get a kids
pumped out by an inflated higher
education system agreed they graduate
and aren't qualified for anything except
perhaps another high school diploma in
iron in turn they essentially guilt
bully and extort industry into
monetizing their hostility there's so
many of them and the numbers grow every
day that they all they all perform and
market for each other
it's a self-sustaining troll bubble that
is rolling and bouncing through our
culture I love it in the rural outskirts
and Rust Belt it's the same except it's
high school educated fast food fed obese
zombies forced into employment and by
the apathetic multinational chains that
have gobbled up local businesses by
price extortion they're hopeless and
fest
ring and troll online I [ __ ] love
that and even started before that surely
they're qualified enough to make he okay
he's a good fall he dropped some freakin
knowledge Wow
I'm just really so special - I like this
guy I see now if not he just released a
special good on you Yanis get out of
here las cruces get him on the podcast
yeah he's at wow I think Andrew Schultz
produced a special gotta get him out
here I like the way he helped us just as
a special dress he's so right about that
- mm-hmm
it's just this higher educational
horseshit Ike Ike you know I went to
high school up in Massachusetts I saw in
the 80s it was starting and I saw it I
used to argue about it all the time I so
dick did this dude I predicted it
should we go to current events it's got
a Carnivale Spanos Brian thanks bro
appreciate that cheesy pie thanks man
if you want good meat no dude I want me
you want grass-fed meat you want meat
that's basically been raised the way
it's supposed to in nature butcher box
dude is it cool if I get me and bring it
over to your house and put on your grill
this mean huh
you can I don't like what you're
insinuating what do you mean I don't
know you're talking about my meat yeah
on your grill you can bring some meat
over as long as butcher box me yeah do
you mainly raised me better for you
better for the animal better for the
environment fact to me and I got this
all ate my all my family eats it is the
best meat in the world whatever state
you have Eve you have to go hunt for me
to get better I did I've know too many
of you had free-range organic chicken
heritage breeds report Wow wild caught
salmon bro it doesn't get better and
they shows up at your door in a box I've
been doing this I've been a butcher box
customer way before they were a sponsor
for 74 I don't know three years Rogan
same thing I'll talk about around that
long
anyways listed also how about turkey
dinner Thanksgiving yeah do they do that
a butcher box yeah every month butcher
box ships and creates a selection of
high quality meats for your grill right
to your home it's all free of
antibiotics
yup miles are no-brainer it's the best
meat ship right to your door nine twelve
more groceries
trips it's the way meat should be
butcher box the most affordable
convenient way to get healthy humanely
raised meat with Thanksgiving right
around the corner and now is the perfect
time to try butcher box
sign up today and get a free turkey plus
$20 off your first box just go to
butcher box.com slash fighter enter
promo code fighter at checkout that's
butcher box com slash fighter or enter
promo code fighter at checkout for a
free turkey in your mouth and plane
always I'm hungry man gobble gobble dude
yeah put your bucks so instagram has
begun testing on a new feature where
they will then fact check posts and put
whether or not it's false information
that's stupid I guess it's what it's
like like legit news outlets or like
right now wise them as new see that's a
tree is what they'll do is so so here's
what here's what it really addresses
Russian Russian BOTS Russian Russian
misinformation campaigns Malay sort of
misinformation campaigns to sway voting
and inclusions that's where Facebook
Tantra yeah a fist occator check I like
to Instagram that's why yes Facebook
tones and why isn't Facebook doing it
Facebook is starting to do it more as
well but they're now spreading it
towards Instagram as well a while now
that kind of but Facebook you can run
like shaming at or though
yeah but Facebook has also been so
Facebook was really taking a task and
they were congressional hearings oh yeah
so they're they're really working to try
to figure out how to stop those things
are you using social media gay I got
away from it so much I'm so far behind
because I just saw I things were so
angry all the time
I used to tweet on Monday Night Football
games I was I was on Twitter all the
time and not during football games and
stuff which is I've known so much in the
sports world especially football I just
tweet snarky comments I gained a
thousand followers on a Sunday night
football game or a Monday Night Football
game just over that just constantly but
then I saw myself doing it in real life
I'd be like great shirt you know that
kind of thing yeah just saying terrible
things
be blooming this is all and I didn't get
into Instagram I started finally doing
Instagram for real in the last couple
months but I was embarrassed by it
because I was so I had so few followers
my daughter was looking at it my son
they're like yeah how do you only have
twenty thousand Instagram followers
you've been on TV for 20 years I'm like
because your dad's old they didn't pay
attention to where you know I could do
it you could do different impressions of
different people yeah but need to sell
takes no matter what yeah but I I mean
for me I've started to do more so like I
do the Monday Morgan motivations now
like I take a quote and have Morgan
Freeman read the quote how's your Morgan
Freeman sometimes a man tries to figure
out where it's going it's spotless Brian
and sometimes he just takes a look away
from the macro they'll go away from them
and listen well now I don't need to it's
just so good here's a patron that's
Morgan Freeman at Frank Caliendo on you
can follow me if you want and stop yeah
I know what you guys get if you can't
spell it the letter C the word alien and
the word do at Frank C alien do but I
years ago on vine I bet on fine cuz
sasso revine me and I did Morgan Freeman
narrates himself
I had no followers will revine me in my
father I gained like a hundred thousand
yeah in between him swallowing lemons
and which my son says to me goes dead
this guy swallows well lemons I'm like I
know I know him he's like you do not
know him like no he wrote Tropic Thunder
I know but it was Morgan Freeman area to
himself it was in the first person and
I'd go toward the refrigerator like
that's when I realized he had no milk
for his Siri and soon Morgan Freeman
would be headed to the grocery store so
there's always silly little things like
that that would create you know a little
senior mind still out know it's gone it
not stick use now but only to watch
videos that have already been posted you
can't post on so nobody now is ticked
off I want to ask you something about
this with the Russian BOTS and stuff
like that either
Russians and I'm not making a bit I'm
actually it's gonna sound bitty but I'm
actually asking for other Russians the
only ones who are really trying to
influence that I mean Chinese maybe I
probably involved I know the Russians
have an actual doesn't everybody in
history but I feel like they don't the
Democrats and everyone has everybody
there's in yeah but narrative yeah and
the United States has me again in its
own cyber cyber misinformation I'm sure
they do
they they couldn't they have to because
everybody else does is when that face
this was surprising to a lot of people
because they were fostering they were
doing deliberate things to the
population at large in the United States
so what they were doing was staging in a
pro Islam anti-islam rally eclipta
success watch you were launching these
massive anti vaccine campaigns we were
like what the [ __ ] is going on those
people and it was it was actually
Russians did you ever watch the
Americans a couple of effects yeah go
back and watch it they've been doing it
forever
oh yeah like it's just drink the cold
waters do whatever they come a turn now
it's unbelievable how you can affect so
many people so quickly cuz all you have
to do is have one person of influence it
kind of did a bombing Lord it's kind of
disappointing people buy into the
[ __ ] well now of course they go now
I think now is I got a little slightly
by this yeah not kind of no there are
plenty of people who still buy
everything I mean I think in an honesty
in all honesty I I think Trump's full of
it but at the same time there there are
some things that you go well it's not
completely raw yeah reported like
unbiased but then he takes it news
couldn't be more I mean
Fox News has become a mouthpiece for the
Republican Party and CNN and MSNBC I
mean the point where CNN's older brass
the senior executives were literally
saying to the younger and not and not
getting anywhere with it saying to their
younger journalists you guys are going
after Trump so much that you're starting
to lose some credibility I mean this is
crazy you see the anchor for Fox News
who left she signed John Smith because
he's been doing forever he's like oh
this isn't why I signed up like this is
what I wanted Shepard Smith was always
getting add antithesis of everything I
think pretty much
was it bar somebody spoke to one of the
men in the Trump administration had to
sit down with Rupert Murdoch and say we
need to that we need we need to be able
to come out on you and your support and
when you listen to Tucker Carlson you
listen to Sean Hannity it's like they
they are they may have something to say
but they just they seem to never take
Trump to task it's you can just predict
where they're gonna fly can't watch
anymore yeah I'd like some news in
general I struggle with all the news
which is a problem because we're in a we
you know comedy the BBC still has is
still somewhat objective I think
somewhat but I think they're coming from
nobody's ever complete I took the
classes the best class ever took was
critical thinking in the mass media
taught by my teacher Greg Hoffman who
wore turtlenecks had a mustache and
never finished a sentence other than but
he he taught us he goes anything that's
reported is always through the eyes of
another human being there so it's always
influenced in some way shape or form now
you take that to the year 2019 and you
add marketing and selling like social
ratings you send that and that's just
it's how can I tell this story it's
telling a story you know you're telling
a story base don't kid yourself Sean
Hannity Don Lemon all these different
these opinion makers on both sides make
a fortune and they are there they are
looking at their [ __ ] ratings they
have to look at their ratings because
the ratings are down and your base are
yes well yeah well that's that jingle
balancing Cooper ball they're all they
do you gotta be fair you have to be fair
but but also when you can start to
predict where somebody's gonna wear a
journalist yeah quote-unquote no problem
it's gonna fall if you're like why am i
I'm not getting information here I know
where you stand because they have to
speak to their base if they don't speak
to their base they lose right who was
the the congressman from Baltimore who
just passed away
big civil rights leader and you guys
Google that for me cuz I'm not that's
the one thing I'm really
had it exactly you're talking yeah and I
should have liked it secretly told logic
oh and you look at some of the articles
that are about Elijah Cummings the first
thing is how much he was fighting with
Donald Trump all the good that he's done
in my entire lifetime and the headline
is fighting with dog you know so he also
yeah you have to remember that when you
say good baltimore has parts of it that
and I'm laying on blame and then our
third world yeah I mean he didn't do
such a good job there are good things
that he did usually when you you
eulogize somebody here along you would
start out with some where's that what
I'm saying is you start out with
something besides Donald Trump I'm not
praising him all over but he I don't
care where you're you right your left
wherever you are on the political
spectrum you you believe in something
and you're doing good for somebody it's
just coming from your point of view Yeah
right you think I always say this to
people you're over there I'm over here
and you would say no you're over there
I'm over here I'm like we're saying the
same thing we're just coming from a
different perspective and we we make
people out to be terrible people for
everything now what people are just
trying they're looking at things
fundamentally in a different way trying
to reach the same the same issue but
having any of you attack it from a
different point of view and you then but
what we instead of doing what people
used to do is try and work it out and
come pranaya compromise is not always
the best way sometimes you take go one
side and then compromise and you go some
a different way in another issue yeah
but it's not you're a bad person because
you think differently for me and I will
never talk to you I'm you're you're
getting rid of your information to hate
and lies and I'm rooted in the truth in
love and that's what people do all the
time which is weird cuz I'm sure some of
your best friends have different plasma
cores yeah there's gummy
yeah I I wanna I wanna I want to
persuade not destroy and that's the idea
what else you got gin but even even
before we go on I'm sorry it's your show
but it's even before we go on it's not
even always persuade it's just like
listen to my side yeah and then
cool and then if we're different we can
agree to walk away but people don't
agree to walk away now
they just keep tweeting at each other
and you know this idea that the stakes
are so high it's this trumpet really
scared the [ __ ] out a lot of people so
they're on the warpath and so people are
terrified that that we're gonna lose our
democracy I understand this is what
happens he think we're actually losing
our democracy I think there's enough
safety nothing I think he's he's really
importance of being civically involved
do you think he'll get impeached no no
absolutely and the resources Russia
probe go not a god no [ __ ] how many
spheres how much how much we saw all the
time but that government doesn't care
resources okay is that the federal
government will just keep spending money
they don't care Ryan yeah can't catch me
I'm the gingerbread man okay I don't
know what that means don't you don't
have to know I don't know if a lot of
people know it oh so you guys have been
talking about this for a long time and
Harvard is actually starting to create
lab-grown meat they're taking
inspiration from a cotton candy machine
oh so they're trying to make the sounds
the meat tastes fibrous by doing the
little layers that cotton candy machines
make when it swirls around edges
swirling a steak they're currently
reverse engineering how me is created
it's gonna be a tiny na to be tough for
us for a while before we get involved in
but the time our kids are our age
they'll have it you're sure yeah [ __ ] it
hundred percent yeah we're not gonna
have five predicted farms will be a
something will look at it look what we
did to cows you think I I think if it's
easy enough to grow on a lab why would
you eat something without a central
nervous system that didn't feel pain I
mean right now it's just technology in
price that's it
that's it there's choking out those
Psychopaths that want to slit the throat
shorten and pigs
well y'all have natural ists will be
able to find those Psychopaths you'll
have heirloom meat which means I want to
go back to the way my forebears cuz my
bio on the table but then there'll be a
lot of science that says we're making
the best meat actually because it's
omega-3 fatty acids better for your body
but doesn't think I'm a house you can be
only God didn't plan it well though the
cows will die off though and we want to
eat as much grazing land
cows don't live that long and they'll
just die off and or they'll be you know
used for other purposes
oh leather stage or well we got leather
leather you know whatever I'm out there
yeah you know we'll all fish you make
leather - all right you may have meat
leather these hell yeah hell yeah
although I'll tell you what you still
can't really replicate good leather in a
lab you can't replicate good fur you
can't it's it's just got a special
something as you rub your that's right
human skin is amazing as well everyone I
didn't think really gif he gave me when
I get you the best blanket of all time
but I thought I looked at it and every
time you got it [ __ ] I gotta beavers had
to die for this worth of really nothing
lob even gave me a beaver blanket yeah I
went through it like count like I
measured the hole I looked online how
big and how big this 524 beavers up 36
beavers guys Dan I don't be good I don't
need that bad juju hey bro I don't give
a [ __ ] wrap your kid in that [ __ ] that's
somebody it's fashion comfy man and and
I've it is so comfy yeah beavers are
trapped and used all the time so I was
like alright I'll make a blanket out of
it and I eat the meat then everyone
every evening every 6bv for those
slaughtered beaver marry whoever that
died in the trap slower we're talking
about the critter right I [ __ ] ate
that meat I don't know world is
happening
I got a freezer full of beaver meat okay
anybody horny there another story
yeah what else you got beavers far the
best I've ever eaten no I swear to god
you eat their tail no you can't eat
their tail but you can but it's a it's a
very solid find a second again you can't
eat their tail but you can can why it's
super chewy and hard to just and throw
with you when you're feeling it Dustin
wrote this hole
Podcast have you ever had beaver tail
gum when no no it's just chewy web Steve
really happy go to Steve Rinella made me
and Rogen some some beaver and it was
it's I'm so sad about everything is the
best meat I've ever had in my life
really I'll eat all the beaver I'll eat
all the beaver and yes you can eat the
tail look people eat it tell me not a
[ __ ] up man yeah I'll only kill
something having to eat then I'll wear
it's fur somebody's being killed besides
a cute little bee here's my problem with
beaver here's my problem of the eating
beaver and here's my problem with beaver
blankets now that I know
forgive me everybody you got to trap
them I don't like that you have to trap
them because then I stray thinking I
want to shoot him so they die quickly
anything you trap that die slowly I
ain't touch that's a problem for me but
I don't know for a fact that the Beavers
the beautiful angel I have your blanket
of the old angled if we see the world
never killed they were killed humanely
and they were killed
systematically back tracker in the
justin throat Amos they were not trapped
and they were not tortured they were
killed like that just wrapped their
stupid little face isn't right over them
it's a way to do it just put like in a
utopia first yeah you know like the
Beavers is like I put their hair right
in the equivalent of a pencil sharp like
no you just have a dam made for them and
it's like look what you made I've hunted
and killed enough deer to know that
there's I don't like doing it I really
don't I love the meat
but I and I think I've dropped every
deer I've ever shot right away because
I'm terrified
I got they call me dead I not for me
that's how you got you and roll you guys
asked me to go hunting I'd probably
shoot that dance just start crying you
well you I don't believe you do think
that you think that but once you because
you're competitive as [ __ ] and once you
add that deer in your sight bro and
we're hungry and we've been looking for
three days I [ __ ] promise you cuz you
want to eat that and I hope but check
this out Snickers back pocket not when
you're not when you're dying for me cuz
I'm thinking about fine sniggers can't
live on Snickers alone you can't imagine
that dehydrator mountain food we have
all you want is to shoot a [ __ ] deer
that I made it right there I may be a
labia maybe bring something with you
they do I brought I brought some jerky
not the same you got to have fresh deer
fresh blood you can eat it right there
and Bambi first blood so this man in New
Jersey for a couple of weeks went around
his neighborhood and it doesn't specify
what type of poop but he went around
smearing poop with gloves on to his
neighbors cars and one storefront
recently they caught him on somebody's
alarm camera so I think it's one of the
Ring those rings they caught him and
he's been arrested well he's just into
that and he probably likes watching
people go oh no but I didn't live a very
exciting life if that's if you get this
rocks off one smell [ __ ] all of your car
door or he lived an extremely exciting
life and this is the only way he can get
that perspective that is a habitable
like he's done everything up is half
full of [ __ ] it's a boy maybe I'm just
full of [ __ ] yeah I think you're right
look at him yeah I don't know that's
interesting he just wants to put poo on
places they're people I'd like get off
on that
obviously Sam strange what I should get
he's trying to make his mark this is a
driver from Georgia and believe it or
not he's actually fine right now what'd
he do look at this I'll show you the
pictures in row here oh my god he ran
into a log truck and you see how bad he
goes so it's from the front he's taxing
huh he said he drives up then you drop
something try to look here at lien
dancing but he leaned down because
otherwise look at this it wouldn't feel
your face won't would through your face
dude that's how they do it in a move
look at that oh well he's 30 or 40 logs
he was leaning down to get some maybe he
was texting yeah maybe was sexy and then
he dropped his phone oh my god only like
minor injuries it took him like 15-20
minutes to a saw him up well there was
that nice onyx tendrá extension
look at that that's crazy how much I had
it come on you and we're not living in a
simulation what what how how does the
timing work out that he ducks in time
for the law to go let's change something
I don't
something doesn't add up the big man
upstairs looking out for him that one up
to the Almighty you don't think this is
the Jesse smollett of woodsmen like the
wake of those came through it you need
how think hello you'd have to do I'm
with this I'm sir see the cattle really
she has he had a calendar Gert why's
that other guy wiping [ __ ] it's no bull
it's like the guy who hit the bear this
this couple was driving and Whistler
whenever they hit there and it flew into
the other a guy was driving this pickup
truck and a bear flew through the guys
windchill and kill them yeah but that's
believable cuz someone died here
this guy's Nissan Xterra that's pretty
hard to fake they're above you I don't
know do like a low I mean what house you
have to get well how is he down there at
the right time
you couldn't time that that's very
straight ncredible you know so small
you'd have to be style also d-dip out
the side there's a moment there's more
to it so he found his head in between
logs somehow his head this was this
around from freakin Expendables 19 I'm
not buying this well you know what
Expendables 100 back a couple cuz there
was a picture of Celine Dion I just have
to see his present in these pictures
no go back she's in between another
couple long go back to where we were
before
Oh cats articles yeah one more this one
yeah now go down go down going back this
one yeah very very skinny she does look
very clickbait damn she looks skinny she
does look really really really skinny
though but she is disgusting 9 major
weight loss she's 9 singing my heart
can't go on every goddamn weekend in
Vegas
it's your stress bro I don't know this
is from today article
is it better yield today huh it looks
like it was it today today so that looks
like a real picture she's always been
thin no yes
too thin that looks healthy what tell
her I'm like go ahead let's go up to her
and say never try beaver meat say how
like gonna let her diet is my beaver how
old is she she likes the tails just
super skinny
what's pretty good e70 son and our lips
are still there have you heard her
lately no oh my god dear mind now that
is crazy you're younger than me you're
her elder how Bobby she's got year
younger than you know you know you guys
look pretty similar right I hate to be
[ __ ] about this you look so no tell him
to take that bad joking take it tonight
damn she's like 51 you just said she's
in her 70s I thought so too I thought
what is that Ted did tells you father
time will go on you know well but you
can't lose that much weight
yeah well I'm jealous she can lose that
much weight she's not eating pizza in
front of hot chicks Yeah right dude
she's had him she's not even there Pete
she's eating pizzas coming back don't
lose so much weight gain [ __ ] weight
slider dance Brian say gain weight girl
I'm not going to you don't tell me
Michael listen to you what else you guys
good just one more good news there's
gonna be a documentary on Patrice O'Neal
like you're just talking about I guess
it's gonna be executive produced with a
bunch of people including Bill burr out
magical and all things comedy all things
coming bill burr now magical there you
go nice a on it yeah good idea
yeah billboard and Patrice were really
close yes yeah yeah very cool man well
looking forward to that Frank Caliendo
I'm gonna be at the Bray improv
starting tomorrow Friday and Saturday
can you do a commercial for me as Donald
Trump or anybody you know that's they'll
take okay who would be it'll sell
tickets it'll sell then as amount of
tickets and that's when the people are
brave good Brian
Allen would be changing their lives
forever there did a single man on a
single stage changing so many laughs at
once he could broadcast without ever
using a satellite people knew what he
was doing they could feel it in their
bones they could feel it in their souls
kay I'm calling the world praying for 25
I don't know what to tell you that's
impressed I'm at Ice House Thursday
night with some funny comics once you're
only 10 p.m. and then November 14th
through the 16th Dallas Allison improv
Salt Lake City wise guys one of my
favorite clubs and then December Kansas
City Jersey 12 13th and 14th Atlantic
City get your tickets t fat K calm oh by
the way if you are on a night Saturday
October 20 go to be Alan it's gonna be
Shaab it's gonna be Rogen it's gonna be
Whitney Cummings it's gonna be Nick
Swardson any more questions for a great
show he says that's the lineup you know
so graphic I'm gonna have Martin make a
graph if you're let's just make graphic
yeah let's get Martin on that graphic
yeah that's what we're that's what we're
doing right now with a p.m. that's a
p.m. on Sunday Comedy Store main room we
will be bringing you there be square -
tag hero has texture rationed all
proceeds go to a very important charity
we are taking no money for this well you
gotta pay me what wait what
please can't buy more beavers um Frank
we appreciate you man Frank you're good
man I plugged some stuff yes the podcast
Caliendo cast with John Homburg oh I
fear for people yeah at Frank Caliendo
on Instagram Twitter everything if you
can't spell Kelly and oh it's the letter
C the word alien in the word do at Frank
C alien do we are doing the happy ending
show at the end or mid-december
number 21st yes in Vanek's yeah a
celebrity theater
I'm sure they can go to your website
Franklin stage comm for me and you are
headlining that show mm means I'm in the
middle somewhere all right listen hey
man let me let me say that this was
really this was a funny thing that you
don't think about so Homburg does the
there's the podcast with me he's
brilliant unbelievable and we just we
start doing back and forth he has a
radio show the best ratings yes I know
him Paul yeah oh he uh best yeah you
know man he might have yeah he's easy
when we go back and forth and we're you
know we create things like will be doing
Jerry Jones from the Dallas Cowboys and
then it'll turn into Jerry Alex Jones
because the frogs are turning people gay
that's exactly what's happening here you
have no I did know so we'll just go into
that kind of thing and we just bounce
stuff back and forth but that celebrity
theater show was really funny because I
John asked me if I'd do it and I was
like sure he's like uh I don't even do
any grilled in this show man I'll tell
you what let's do the rest of the promo
that way
sure so he said man I ain't doing it who
you Chris Evans well spider 2 y banana
there man so he's I didn't think about
it though like and I don't care in the
end but it's like just one of those
things like I said I'll do the show and
then I see Brian Carlin Frank Caliendo
and then they got some all had a break
that's just like that's not fair
but I'd okay it doesn't matter me you're
a hero a legend I tell you what man you
know who you are
the comedic elite Camille Leo Mac I
would not have traded man what was
Camille as the that was the wife fun
Cosby Show man Camille it's incredible
it's unorthodox man I love that mother
I'm going to you know do you know him
pretty well
Gruden yeah yeah he'll text me I'm such
a fan of his
we know I love the shot your fan you'll
start doing this we started this she'll
start doing this would be like you'll
just start to see him good you doing man
he texted me once at 3 in the morning
which i think is his lunch time he's
like I just got done doing a commercial
where I did an impersonation of you like
I didn't I was too scared to ask which
one it was I think it's the one where
he's talking to the tire it's like you
gotta get in there
man yeah time do you have tank I tell ya
so when I met him Super Bowl in New
Orleans and at Fox they didn't care if I
did impressions of somebody they liked
just go surprise him I did like a.j
glaziers NFL I'm sorry it's unbelievable
how great this is and then it becomes
Bobby Flay ting them know if it's right
but it's you could do anybody over at
Fox ESPN they would always check like
we're gonna do shefter we'll see if it's
ok with shefter and they couldn't call
of course you can just do me anytime you
want have no problem with it I didn't
think it sounds like me
would let him do it so they check they
checked with Gruden and they wanted me
to meet him so this is 810 years ago now
I got up there he's just holding the
coffee just making that Gruden face he's
right there I go up to me just doing it
back he's like so your guy who does me
huh I'm like yeah he's like where are
you from and I looked up where he was
from so I said that Sandusky Ohio it's
like really I'm like no he's like good
cuz you were blowing my mind was weird
stuff right there but even he brought me
into this so you wouldn't look at that
guy me it's like that Spiderman meme
right there man that came from us man
more of a dick like me I don't know
maybe I'm not a dick good thing on hard
nights dude if you know people that
played for Gruden before it's he cusses
a lot oh yeah uh done but hard nights
they edit it all out no they want some
not an execution ton not like yes man
yeah yeah the first time I went in there
when it was last year when they played
him when when they played the Cardinals
and came through Phoenix
I said does John swear all they're like
not really and I hear me starts yelling
I'm like he does swear a little bit like
every few words I loved him as a
commentator I thought he was amazed
always and he's fit he's so good he's a
winner he can do whatever he wants I
texted him before he got the job because
Adam Schefter the NFL insider had talked
about it on Twitter saying that looks
like Gruden might be entertaining the
thought of going to back to the Raiders
the silver and black might
have Jon Gruden as their coach once
again I texted girlies like tell you
what man I love that team I'm like is he
telling me this is before there's like
months before it's announced like I
think he's kind of tell him he's like
it's hard to turn that down man also ten
million dollars a year mine some good
cash man
how many beaver blankets you could buy
with that I love it
well Frank we appreciate you yo man John
thanks guys thanks thank you
yes the fighter and the kid and Frank
we're out